the sound you hear emanating from your
speakers that low ominous tone is not a
signal problem or a defect of poor
recording it's but a sample of what
brings us all the way to the American
Southwest to investigate an infamous
phenomenon known simply as the Taos hum
this October on Friday the 13th from an
executive producer of The Walking Dead
and an executive producer of the x-files
from six terrifying tales based on the
podcast phenomena lore until then we
offer you this short film inspired by
the series I'm Stephen ocelli I'm a
professor of anatomy and physiology at
st. Joseph's College the Taos hum is a
strange phenomenon that happens in a
town called Taos New Mexico what it is
basically is people in Taos about 2% of
the people hear this strange humming
sound or this buzzing sound that really
irritates them gets into their heads
gives some headaches because some
anxiety gives some fears and people
don't know really where it's coming from
this persistent sound emerges seemingly
from nowhere and plagues those who hear
it day and night without relief first
thought to be a disorder consistent with
the high-pitched ringing of tinnitus
doctors have become puzzled by patients
accounts that they are able to move
freely toward or away from the phantom
sound they describe it as maybe a low
rumble of a diesel engine or maybe a
really loud refrigerator noise and while
the description of the sound is
consistent from all who claimed to hear
it the intensity varies widely
a dull annoyance to some but an
unyielding nightmare for others
it ruins people's lives because they can
never get away from the sound all day
all the time in your ears in your head
some people have been driven to suicide
because of the Taos hum it really does
affect the patient's really badly some
scientists theorized that the hum could
be caused by regional seismic shifts
while others blame low-frequency radio
signals used by the military that
classified sites in the desert if you
want to go down the conspiracy route
some people talk about the US military
using elf technology elf technology
could also be used against your enemies
as a type of warfare where it will cause
headaches and will cause noises to be
heard in the ears and ringing in the
ears and it will drive your enemies
crazy if you make the frequency perfect
to wear it really irritates them others
still look to the Navajo Apache and Hopi
teachings that identify the home as the
song of long-lost spirits trying to
speak to us from the other side New
Mexico is one of those areas that's
still rich in the culture of the Native
Americans and they believe that it's the
earth the earth is talking to you
in the end we may never truly understand
the origin or meaning behind the sound
and it seems those affected must resign
themselves to its effect or uproot their
entire lives to move away from but
somewhere resonating in the depths
beneath the surface the unseen source
continues to faithfully haunt for anyone
who will listen
you
you